bonjour à tous bonjour monsieur
rebonjour puisqu'on vous avez déjà
auditionné une première fois donc dans
le cadre des travaux de la commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie des médicaments
et choix de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française
votre premier audition par la commission
d'enquête nous avait permis d'aborder
des sujets assez nombreux relatifs à la
fixation des prix plus largement à la
régulation des dépenses de médicaments
mais les auditionnels que nous les
industriels pardon que nous avons
auditionné ayant mis en avant
l'incidence du prix du médicament et
plus largement de la rentabilité de
certaines spécialités sur les
difficultés d'approvisionnement
constater nous avons souhaité vous
réentendre aujourd'hui pour approfondir
certaines questions que qui avait été
abordées lors de cette première audition
dans le contexte d'inflation que nous
connaissions et alors que le
gouvernement a annoncé un moratoire sur
la baisse des prix nous souhaitions
d'abord que cette audition permette
d'approfondir la question du prix des
médicaments matures parce que c'est un
élément très important qui est apparu
dans nos auditions et dans les visites
de terrain et surtout de sa rigidité
audition auditionnée par notre
commission d'enquête le LEM a affirmé
que l'article 28 de l'accord cadre
permettant au CEPS d'accorder des
hausses de prix lorsqu'il existe un
risque important pesant sur la
production ou la commercialisation d'un
médicament était extrêmement peu utilisé
en fait dans la réalité et nous
souhaitons que vous puissiez nous
indiquer ce qu'il en est réellement et
les causes si ça se révèle exact par
ailleurs et alors qu'un nouveau critère
de fixation du prix tenant à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement du marché français
que garantit l'implantation des sites de
production a été ajouté par le
législateur nous souhaiterions que vous
puissiez nous préciser dans quelle
mesure les médicaments matures d'or et
déjà inscrit au remboursement pourront
en bénéficier c'est une question moins
qui m'a été posée à titre personnel
lorsque j'ai été faire une visite à Agen
sur l'unité de production du PSA
enfin le produit de la clause de
sauvegarde pour 2021 et 2022 récemment
révélé s'avère très supérieur aux années
précédentes de nombreux industriels que
nous avons auditionnées ont souligné les
difficultés soulevées par ce dispositif
celui-ci ne tient compte ni de l'intérêt
thérapeutique des médicaments
ni de leur criticité industrielle vous
nous direz comment vous appréhendez la
place prise par la clause de sauvegarde
dans cette régulation
et s'il faut rechercher un moyen d'en
exonérer les médicaments les plus
indispensables à la prise en charge des
patients
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets qui sont
cruciaux je vais vous céder la parole
donc avec un comme la dernière fois un
propos introductif et puis notre notre
rapporteur Laurence Cohen vous posera
une première série de questions vous
connaissez le processus je précise parce
que c'est important que l'audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera bien entendu
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié voilà
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle que nous sommes dans le cadre
d'une commission d'enquête et que des
faux témoignages sont passibles de peine
prévue aux articles 434 13 434 434 15 du
code pénal et donc je vous invite à
prêter serment
en allumant le micro merci
donc je vous de nous dire que la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure je le
jure
madame la vice-présidente et messieurs
bonjour comme vous l'avez comme vous
l'avez souligné nous étions déjà venus
il y a je crois trois mois vers le début
de votre travaux depuis lors nous avons
suivi dans la mesure du possible le
déroulement de ces travaux les
nombreuses auditions auxquelles vous
avez procédé
nous avons vu que vous aviez engrangé un
grand nombre d'informations sans doute
un grand nombre d'interrogations aussi
et dans ces conditions il nous
paraissait tout à fait naturel de
revenir devant vous à ce stade de vos
travaux nous revenons dans le même état
d'esprit c'est-à-dire que nous nous
efforcerons d'apporter toutes les
informations
utiles que ce soit oralement ou que ce
soit via la transmission de documents et
voilà mon premier message prélim c'est
que nous sommes à votre disposition
alors j'ai bien entendu les les trois
premiers thèmes que vous avez évoqué les
deux premiers qui sont l'utilisation de
l'article 28 de la corde sur les hausses
de prix ou l'article 65 de la LFSS
2022 qui autorise un différentiel de de
prix au titre de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement que garantit la
localisation des sites de production les
deux premiers sont directement de notre
ressort et je dirais son entre quotidien
le troisième thème que vous avez évoqué
celui de la clause de sauvegarde nous
concerne naturellement dans la mesure où
il a un impact significatif sur les
entreprises et donc indirectement sur
les relations que nous avons avec les
entreprises mais comme vous le savez ce
n'est pas un sujet sur américaine nous
nous sommes directement à la manoeuvre
je dirais donc nous efforcerons de
répondre aussi à vos questions sur ce
sujet là bien entendu mais pas avec le
même degré de de pertinence que nous ne
pouvons le faire je l'espère en tout cas
pour l'article 28 et l'article 65 alors
je ne sais pas comment vous voulez que
l'on procède est-ce que vous posez des
questions plus précises ou est-ce que je
commence à répondre sur les points que
je viens de rappeler le mieux c'est de
répondre aux trois questions que qu'on a
posées en propos introductif très bien
pour ce qui est de pour ce qui est de
l'article 28 donc je rappelle qu'il
s'agit d'un article qui permet
au comité à la demande d'entreprise de
procéder à des hausses de prix c'est un
article qui figure dans l'accord cadre
de 2021 et je dirais que si on regarde
un peu dans le rétroviseur sur les
dernières années on a eu plusieurs
phases dans sa mise en oeuvre il y a eu
le tout début et là je vais être un peu
imprécis dans la datation parce que
en réalité
nous avons commencé à appliquer cet
article je dois le dire un petit peu
avant la signature de la corde c'est à
dire que la corde c'est un
gros travail il est assez épais et nous
avions un accord avec le LEM sur sur cet
article là avant que la signature n'a
été apposée formellement donc il y a
quelques
il y a quelques produits sur lesquels
nous avons pu procéder à des hausses
dans les conditions de l'article 28
avant même qu'il n'ait été signé mais on
est dans le registre de l'accord
conventionnel dans tous les cas et je le
signale ce n'est pas anecdotique parce
que soit juste soit juste après la
signature
nous avons procédé à des hausse qui
était d'ampleur et d'impact tout à fait
significatif
puisque c'est c'est adéos de classe
c'est-à-dire de prix pour une classe
entière que nous avions pu procéder vous
savez que cet article a été écrit pour
des hausses de prix au cas par cas on
est certainement pas dans un outil
macroéconomique qui porte hausse de tous
les prix par exemple au regard de
l'inflation ce n'est pas comme cela que
cela marche on est vraiment dans un
article qui s'applique au cas par cas
mais il est précisé dans l'article que
dans certains cas
le comité j'y reviendrai le comité peut
procéder à une hausse pour tout ou
partie d'une classe
lorsque plusieurs produits au sein d'une
même classe sont confrontés à même choc
portant sur les coûts et c'est ce que
nous avions fait et nous l'avions fait
pour d'une part les immunoglobulines et
on sait qu'il y avait des tensions sur
l'offre au niveau mondial à ce moment là
sur les héparines là-bas pourra
moléculaire les HBPM
parce que tous les produits de cette
classe étaient confrontés à un même choc
qui était la hausse du coup de la
matière première à travers tous les
produits dérivés du port au moment où la
fièvre porcine africaine s'est vissait
en Chine avec un impact majeur sur le
marché et nous l'avons fait aussi je me
souviens plus précisément du timing une
hausse de classe également dans le cas
des vaccins anti-grippaux donc nous
avions eu en début de période si on
regarde
2021-2023
au fin 2020 jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
nous avons eu des séances de classe qui
était pour des nombres de produits et
pour des montants tout à fait
significatif
ensuite nous avons été confrontés au cas
normal je dirais ou au cas le plus
courant de l'article 28 c'est à dire des
laboratoires qui déposent un dossier de
demande de hausse pour un produit donné
je pense que nous vous avions donné les
statistiques je ne les ai plus
directement en tête mais on avait eu on
a eu ainsi durant l'année 2021 je crois
15 ou 17 produits qui ont été qui ont
été concernés donc la règle c'est que
le fonctionnement de cet article et le
suivant une entreprise est confrontée à
une difficulté qui lui fait craindre de
devoir retirer un produit du marché ce
qui écrit clairement c'est que à ce
moment-là elle nous informe elle vient
nous voir si le faux elle nous explique
quelle est la situation et nous allons
regarder à ce moment là plusieurs choses
nous allons regarder quel est l'état du
marché pour se produire pour les
produits analogues pour les comparateurs
pour estimer s'il y a un enjeu s'il y a
un risque en cas de retrait de ce
produit
la façon la plus simple de répondre à
cette question c'est où le début en tout
cas cela consiste à regarder quelles
sont les comparateurs un produit qui est
unique si effectivement il se retire on
n'a pas besoin d'un raisonnement très
élaboré pour conclure que il va y avoir
un manque et éventuellement une perte de
chance ou un risque pour les pour les
patients un produit qui est le 12e dans
sa catégorie et qui est le seul à venir
nous voir si jamais il a des difficultés
et bien on peut se dire que c'est la vie
des entreprises et que si les autres ne
sont pas confrontés au même risque de de
retrait et bien le marché pourra faire
sans lui donc on examine cette dimension
là et ensuite on demande une
documentation tout à fait précise enfin
ou simultanément on demande une
documentation tout à fait précise à
l'entreprise pour qu'elle nous justifie
qu'est-ce qu'il fait que jusqu'à présent
le produit pouvait commercialisée en
France et que demain éventuellement il
ne pourrait plus l'être donc la priori
ou l'idée que l'on avait au moment de la
de la rédaction de cet article c'est que
vraisemblablement il s'était produit au
cours de la période récente un choc est
typiquement un choc de coût donc les
coûts sont plus élevés si le prix reste
constant le laboratoire ne peut plus ou
considère qu'il n'est plus viable pour
lui de commercialiser le marché en
France donc nous demandons aux
entreprises de documenter précisément le
choc de coût auquel elles ont été
soumises pour le faire d'une manière
transparente nous avons adressé aux
entreprises ce qu'on appelle en très
mauvais français en template enfin un
schéma de
renseigner avec des informations et on
se focalise sur un choc de coût alors
initialement dans les débuts de cet
article
nous avions une lecture assez stricte de
l'article qui était lui-même assez
précis donc premièrement comme je vous
l'indiquais regardez s'il y avait les
comparateurs et on s'était posé comme
principe de départ que s'il y avait
plusieurs comparateurs et bien on
pouvait considérer que le marché pouvait
absorber le retrait éventuel de ce
produit dès lors que les autres
comparateurs n'avaient pas fait le même
type de demande avec le même type de
d'arguments de coûts c'était un premier
principe et le deuxième au-delà de
l'éligibilité portée sur le montant de
hausse de prix que nous pouvions
accorder en retour pour un produit
éligible et là les choses étaient
simples on regardait quel était on
demandait quel était le poste de coût
qui avait fortement augmenté et qui
produisait ce déséquilibre sur le marché
et on avait même été plus précis
puisqu'on disait que on voulait regarder
le coût de la matière première
alors on avait quand même expliqué qu'il
pouvait y avoir d'autres circonstances
et que à défaut de la matière première
on voulait bien regarder un autre poste
de coup qui serait responsable de ceux
des équilibre nouveau donc voyez c'était
assez strict est-ce qu'il y a des
comparateurs première question pour
déterminer les ligibilité et
deuxièmement le quelle est la hausse de
coût et qu'elle est spécifiquement la
hausse du coût de la matière première et
la dernière phase c'est donc d'attribuer
une hausse de prix et le montant de
hausse enfin le quantum de hausse que
l'on accordait c'était simplement
l'impact du choc de coût donc une fois
que le choc de coût est documenté si ça
a un impact de 10 centimes ou de 1 euro
sur le sur le sur le prix de production
et bien on augmente le sur le coup de
production on augmente le prix de 1 euro
voilà c'était assez simple mais comme je
vous le disais c'était assez stricte
alors on avait simplement préciser
que donc on pouvait regarder un autre
poste de coût que la que la matière
première d'une part et pour être plus
précis ce n'était pas écrit dans
l'article mais on l'avait dit
publiquement de nombreuses reprises si
on était dans une situation de
relocalisation le coût associé à cette
le surcoût ou l'impact sur le coup
associé à cette relocalisation pouvait
également être pris en compte pour
calculer la hausse de prix que nous
pouvions accorder
voilà quel était la partie la plus
stricte de l'application de l'accord
mais néanmoins dès le début nous avions
introduit un
chapitre pour permettre de traiter de
manière plus fine des situations
spécifiques c'est l'alinéa 5 de
l'article dont on va reparler ensuite
sur les orientations que nous avons
reçues plus récemment donc cette alinéa
5 indiquer que et indique toujours que
même dans une situation où il y a
plusieurs comparateurs et que a priori
on aurait considéré comme non éligible
le comité pouvait
prononcer une hausse de prix donc il
pouvait déclarer les éligibilité
l'article sous les yeux je sais pas si
tu si tu l'as enfin au titre d'un motif
de santé publique donc un motif de santé
publique c'est ce n'est pas il n'y a pas
un label il n'y a pas c'est pas quelque
chose qui est écrit dans un avis de la
Haute Autorité de santé c'est davantage
laisser à l'appréciation du comité et
pour dire les choses sur le mode de
fonctionnement au sein du comité quand
nous avons ce type de sujet nous passons
d'abord que la parole à la Direction
générale de la santé qui est la plus à
même de d'apprécier le besoin qu'il y a
en matière de santé publique et de
d'accès des patients à des soins
indispensables donc cet article cette
alinéa 5 qui nous permettait de
prononcer une éligibilité était là
depuis l'entrée depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de l'article et c'est lui qui
mentionnait la possibilité d'accorder
une hausse pour tout ou partie d'une
classe et donc c'est destiné à 5 qui
correspondait typiquement à la situation
des des immunoglobulines que j'ai des
vaccins que j'avais cité dans dans mon
introduction voilà où nous en étiez nous
en étions et c'est sur cette base là que
nous avons prononcé un certain nombre de
hausse en 2021 2022 ce qu'il s'est passé
ensuite ou dans ces mois là c'est que on
a eu un changement de contexte
macroéconomique cette fois-ci avec la
hausse de l'inflation la hausse de d'un
certain nombre de coups un sujet que
vous connaissez bien et dans les
entreprises ont eu l'occasion de vous
parler abondamment je pense et là nous
avons eu une difficulté parce que
beaucoup de d'entreprises
se tourner vers nous et vers cet article
28 en nous disant utilisant l'article 28
pour compenser la situation d'inflation
mais la situation d'inflation c'est un
phénomène macroéconomique et ce n'est
pas à cette fin qui a été rédigé cet
article 28 qui comme je voulais indiquer
et était un article à destiné à traiter
des situations au cas par cas donc on a
les pas s'appuyer sur cet article 28
pour dire la hausse des prix en France
et de 5% 6% et donc on va relever vos
prix de 5 ou 6%. donc il y avait une
première ambiguïté qu'il fallait lever
et je crois qu'elle a été et cet article
est resté un article d'application
microéconomique
ce que nous avons constaté
progressivement c'est que nous
accordions des hausses de prix
mais nous savions que cet article
produisait également un certain nombre
de frustrations ou de critiques de la
part des entreprises à deux égards d'une
part parce que certaines étaient
déclarées certaines demandes étaient
déclarées non éligibles
et d'autre part parce que bien souvent
nous avons accordé des hausses de prix
mais qui étaient des hausses de prix
beaucoup moins importantes que celle que
réclamer les entreprises donc de manière
un peu paradoxale nous nous sommes
retrouvés dans une situation qui n'est
pas la plus habituelle pour le comité
qui est la situation où nous accordons
des hausse de prix et où les entreprises
protestées parce que c'est hausse de
prix mais n’était pas suffisante donc il
y avait un besoin de clarification sur
cet article et on arrive à ce moment-là
à la troisième phase de la mise en
oeuvre c'est les orientations qui ont
été annoncées publiquement
par les ministres courants février et
qui ont été donnés formellement aux
membres du comité économique pour faire
preuve de plus de flexibilité dans la
mise en oeuvre de de cet accord et la
flexibilité ce qui nous a été demandé
explicitement c'est de la faire jouer
notamment au niveau de du fameux alinéa
5 de cet article c'est à dire la
possibilité de mettre en avant un besoin
de santé publique donc en pratique nous
avons
depuis cette époque là et donc depuis
notre depuis l'audition
d'il y a il y a quelques mois de devant
vous nous essayons d'appliquer l'article
face à des demandes des entreprises avec
plus de flexibilité sur l'éligibilité et
d'autre part
en accordant pour ce qui est du quantum
de hausse de prix
en prenant en compte pardon en prenant
en compte un ensemble de coûts beaucoup
plus larges j'avais parlé du coup d'un
poste de coût nous prenons en compte
l'ensemble des coûts qui sont liés à la
production
à condition naturellement qu'ils aient
été bien documentés donc voilà comment
se passe les choses nous continuons
d'avoir alors nous avons une forte
accélération des des demandes depuis ce
moment-là
et nous continuons de susciter nous le
savons un certain nombre de frustrations
mais avec une application plus
volontariste de l'article je vois que
vous voulez je vais passer la parole à
un rapporteur qui parce que pour avoir
plus de
dynamisme dans le dialogue je pense
qu'il vous prendrent thématique par
thématique et pour éviter les pengers de
propos
je vais réagir par rapport à
effectivement ce que vous nous avez
donné comme comme précision alors un peu
avec avec ma liste c'est à dire que on a
beaucoup de poids au niveau du Sénat et
et nos auditions sont suivies puisque il
y a eu un changement visiblement depuis
la première audition où il y a plus de
flexibilité par rapport à l'alinéa 5 bon
ça c'est c'est un peu malicieux mais bon
il faut il faut utiliser les choses de
manière positive moi ce que je voudrais
savoir exactement c'est que parce que je
sais quand même temps votre mission
extrêmement lourde et vous n'avez pas
pléthore de de personnel pour vous
acquitter toutes vos toutes vos missions
et
par rapport à ce que vous nous avez dit
en fait quel est le temps qu'il vous
faut pour évaluer si l'entreprise était
ligible ou pas parce que effectivement
ça ça demande un examen
minutieux sérieux et et en même temps
rapide puisque
si l'entreprise vous alerte c'est que
elle vit des difficultés et qu'il peut y
avoir comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
souligné la disparition
éventuellement d'un médicament or et
c'est bien que vous ayez dit lors de
cette audition monsieur bouillou que
vous êtes sensible la disparition des
médicaments parce que lors d'une de nos
auditions quelqu'un avait remis en cause
cette ce critère par rapport à votre
sensibilité donc quel est quel est le
temps dont vous avez besoin c'est ma
première question
ma deuxième question c'est que ce qui
nous a semblé c'est que finalement
cet article était relativement peu
utilisé par par les entreprises alors
est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
parce que c'est trop complexe est-ce que
c'est parce que c'est méconnu voilà ça
c'est autour de cette question et enfin
la troisième question c'est que la
lors de l'audition de la DGSS elle
souhaitait que il puisse y avoir une un
nouveau critère qui soit introduit dans
cet article 28
c'était la forme galénique est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne une
bonne idée ou pas voilà les trois les
trois questions que j'ai à part à partir
de vos propos
alors sur le temps qu'il nous faut pour
pour évaluer
je dirais qu'il est assez variable
malheureusement je peux pas vous donner
une réponse ou une statistique on a
encore sur des sur des trop petits
nombres mais surtout je crois que le
premier le premier point c'est
est-ce que le dossier est suffisamment
documenté
si nous avons une documentation précise
de l'évolution des postes de coûts
au cours des trois quatre dernières
années nous pouvons aller assez vite il
y a pas mal de dossiers sur lesquels
passons déjà beaucoup de temps en
échange avec l'entreprise pour
pour avoir les informations il est
arrivé que des entreprises nous disent
vous voulez avoir telle information sur
les coûts
je n'ai pas les moyens vous parlez des
moyens du CEPS une entreprise nous dit
je n'ai pas les moyens personnels pour
répondre à votre question il va me
falloir plusieurs semaines
que voulez-vous faire on accorde la
hausse sans avoir de documentation non
on attend d'avoir la documentation c'est
pas c'est pas un cas général mais mais
c'est pour vous dire que
la première phase c'est de s'assurer que
on a vraiment l'information
pardonnez-moi là tout de suite ça me
vient à l'esprit c'est que du coup parce
qu'on a vu quand même une différence si
vous voulez entre les grands labos qui
ont les rins solides qui ont des
personnels conséquents et les PME et les
PME qui sont en souffrance un certain
nombre donc là on voit très bien que
effectivement un grand labo je donnerais
aucun nom étant capacité de vous fournir
tout ce que vous voulez hyper bien
nettoyer etc en un temps record si je
puis dire par contre les petits labos
ils vont avoir beaucoup plus de
difficultés donc déjà là ces
discriminant ou discriminatoires donc
comment est-ce qu'on peut justement
essayer de combler ça parce que c'est
profondément juste
plus regrettable que finalement c'est
souvent les PME qui sont sur les
médicaments matures
donc ceux qui sont justement visés par
la question du prix donc on n'a pas de
doute là-dessus et on en a bien
conscience on a d'un côté des
laboratoires qui sont capables de nous
déposer des dizaines de dossiers
simultanément et vous avez d'autre part
des petites entreprises qui nous posent
un ou deux dossiers et qui nous disent
il me faut du temps pour le documenter
mais en même temps encore une fois
j'imagine quand vous impassez le le
dossier les informations que l'on que
l'on demande c'est pas des c'est pas des
dizaines de questions ce sont des
informations qui sont
assez
je ne sais pas si elles sont assez
simples en tout cas elles sont très
classiques quels sont les quels sont les
postes de coûts sur lesquels vous avez
suivi vous avez subi un choc
en réalité la plupart des entreprises
arrivent à y répondre une des
difficultés que nous avons et là on en
vient sur les sujets de fonds de
l'application ou parfois de malentendus
sur l'application de cet article c'est
que nous avons beaucoup de demandes
d'entreprises qui ne nous demandent pas
de compenser un choc de coût lié à la
production elle nous demande autre chose
vous avez des entreprises qui nous
disent mon prix n'a pas été augmenté
depuis 10 ans 20 ans ou 30 ans bon le
laboratoire le comité lui se dit la
logique du système et que les prix est
plutôt tendance à baisser au bout de 10
ans 20 ans 30 ans donc il n'est pas eu
de hausse
n'est pas une surprise complète pour une
molécule qui est restée à l'identique
mais on a des laboratoires qui nous
disent depuis 20 ans ou 30 ans les cours
ont augmenté les prix n'ont pas augmenté
donc il faut que vous le compensiez mais
vous voyez bien sur ce que je vous ai
dit sur l'article 28 tel qu'il a été
consigné par nous et par le l'aime que
le sujet que l'on prêtait n'était pas
directement celui là donc ça c'est un
premier type de difficulté
récupérer enfin aider une entreprise à
surmonter une érosion de son taux de
marge qui est dû à de nombreux facteurs
depuis une durée qui peut être de
plusieurs décennies ce n'est pas dans
cet esprit qui a été écrit l'article 28
il y a eu il y a une deuxième demande
qui nous a été formulée et parfois de
manière explicite qui consiste à
rétablir un niveau de profilabilité en
compensant le surcoût qui est lié cette
année à l'application de la clause de
sauvegarde pour les génériques
ce qui est une situation un peu
délicate pour un comité à qui un
laboratoire revient et dit une politique
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement
entraîne un surcoût je m'adresse au CEPS
pour comprendre l'impact d'une politique
mise en place par le gouvernement
c'est une situation complexe et je vous
assure que nous avons eu ce genre de ce
genre de discussion souvent oralement
soit soit par écrit et l'article 28 n'a
pas été fait pour cela donc c'est vrai
je vous disais qu'on a conscience de
susciter un certain nombre de
frustration parce que des entreprises
qui qui arrivent avec cet objectif
constate que nous ne leur donnons pas
satisfaction et quand au cas
d'entreprise qui je reviens à votre
point initial parce qu'il était
important il y a eu une PME qui n'a pas
beaucoup de moyens etc nous avons le cas
d'entreprise qui nous disent on a du mal
à documenter la hausse de coûts
on va le faire ça va nous prendre du
temps mais sachez que
si vous compensez la hausse de coût ça
ne nous suffira pas ça sera trop faible
par rapport à nos problèmes vous avez
des entreprises qui nous disent cela et
je pense que ce sont des entreprises que
vous connaissez
et dans ce cas-là du côté du CEPS voilà
quand on vous dit explicitement
on a une revendication qui ne correspond
pas à ce qui figurent dans la corcadre
ce qui figure dans la corps cadre va
vous permettre peut-être vous ceps de
nous accorder une hausse de x% mais ce
que nous voulons c'est 5 fois cela
voilà c'est une situation qui est
complexe
alors combien d'entreprises vont dire
combien d'entreprises ont eu recours
alors en nombre d'entreprises je ne le
sais pas en nombre de dossiers je vous
avais dit que l'an dernier je crois de
mémoire qu'on avait eu 15 ou 17 demandes
cette année depuis février nous avons eu
45 dossiers donc ça vous donne une idée
de
l'accélérations
comme vous le disiez ça prend du temps
notamment le temps d'échange avec les
entreprises pour pour préciser les
demandes je crois que nous avons une je
peux me tromper d'un ou deux de d'une ou
deux unités je crois que nous avons une
douzaine de dossiers qui sont en cours
parmi les 45 quand ils sont encore en
cours parce que ils ont été déposés
tardivement ou parce que on est en phase
de d'échange d'informations nous avons
eu une vingtaine de dossiers un peu plus
qui ont été déclarés non éligibles et
non éligible même avec la flexibilité
qui est
qui est appliquée par les membres nous
avons des entreprises qui nous ont
déposées des dossiers en disant il
s'agit de produits qui ne sont pas
essentiels
qui ont des comparateurs
bon et nous avons
dit 11 12 je ne sais plus dossier qui
sont éligibles dans certains sont
arrivés au bout et d'autres ne sont pas
encore
arrivés au bout
et parce que la situation quantitative
en nombre d'entreprises après il y a des
demandes d'ampleur différentes bien
entendu Corinne c'était sur ce point-là
précis
et merci madame la Présidente c'était
sur sur cet article s'attaque le 28
j'avais des questions puisqu'on parle
pris parlons un petit peu sous en 2021
sur sur les augmentations de prix que
vous avez accordé qu'est-ce que ça
représente en volume au total en montant
de dépenses pour l'assurance maladie et
plus largement parce qu'on voit bien
qu'on tourne toujours autour des fameux
prix et vous l'avez vous avez évoqué le
modèle notre modèle économique sur sur
le secteur du médicament quel est votre
niveau d'influence quels sont vos
relations avec le ministère et la CNAM
au monde l'écriture du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale parce
que là vous êtes sollicité pour des
augmentations de prix alors que tous les
ans alors ce sont pas forcément les
mêmes médicaments mais tous les ans on
demande au secteur du médicament un
effort 800 millions un milliard on est
allés jusqu'à 1 milliard et demi de
baisse soit sur les dispositifs médicaux
soit sur le médicament souvent sur le
médicament donc
avec ce système là
nourrit l'autre et comment un moment
donné vous en tant que ceps vous avez
vous alerter en disant ça va punir quoi
parce que vous voyez ce que je veux dire
voilà j'ai et si dernière question pour
rester sur des aspects financiers est-ce
que par rapport à cet article 28 en face
vous avez une enveloppe financière en
disant ben voilà cet article 28 vous
pouvez l'activer mais voilà pas au-delà
de temps
pardon pour ces questions très terre à
terre non non pas du tout il y a il y a
deux aspects il y a l'article 28
lui-même vous avez commencé fini par
l'article 28 et puis il y a la question
du de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et de du montant global
de la régulation au sujet sur lequel on
remettra peut-être de manière pleine
puisque c'était votre
votre propos de l'introduction le
montant 2021 je me tourne c'est quelques
unités le montant 2021 pour les dossiers
dont on parle ça ne dépasse pas quelques
millions mais pour vous pour cadrer avec
ce qu'on vous a dit au début le
l'augmentation liée aux immunoglobulines
elle représente plus 120 millions
l'augmentation liée au vaccin
anti-grippaux ça doit représenter pour
une campagne de l'ordre de une
quarantaine de millions
voilà mais effectivement les dossiers
qui nous ont été soumis depuis le mois
de février nous ne sommes pas arrivés au
terme je vous ai dit de l'instruction de
ces 45 dossiers et puis il y en aura
certainement d'autres là nous sommes sur
des montants beaucoup plus modestes on a
des demandes qui portent parfois sur un
million voire moins c'est ce genre de
dossier que nous avons à l'heure
actuelle sur le sur la table et pour
répondre à votre question madame pour
savoir si nous avons une enveloppe pour
séos la réponse est non nous n'avons pas
de nous n'avons pas de d'enveloppe pour
la pour la hausse alors je ne sais pas
si vous voulez qu'on continue sur
l'article 28 ou si vous voulez que qu'on
fasse sur la la clause de sauvegarde
ou l'article 65
on prend le deuxième sujet oui avec la
corne de la rapporteur le deuxième sujet
c'est à dire la clause de sauvegarde ou
votre deuxième sujet qui est
sur la clause sur la
la
sur la clause de sauvegarde pour
compléter les propos qui ont déjà été
tenus ce qui nous intéresse si vous
voulez il y a plusieurs choses parce que
dans les auditions on a été on a été
saisi par plusieurs additionnés en nous
disant c'est quelque chose de complexe
parce que en fait on ne sait pas à on ne
peut pas prévoir c'est pas c'est après
coup qu'on sait combien on va devoir
débourser pardon donc c'est quand même
assez complexe pour les entreprises et
là encore je pense en tout cas nous ce
qui a attiré notre attention au niveau
de la commission d'enquête c'est le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de différence entre
les entreprises que ce soit une PME que
ce soit un grand labo c'est traités
exactement de la même façon or ils n'ont
pas les mêmes les mêmes possibilités
donc peut-être essayer de réfléchir
réfléchir là-dessus et puis je vais
pousser un petit peu plus loin puisque à
la fois on dans un dans un constat mais
notre rapport va aboutir à des
recommandations et des recommandations
pour essayer effectivement de
d'améliorer le système et de faire en
sorte que il y ait de moins en moins de
pénurie voire qui en est plus du tout
donc je voudrais que vous puissiez en
tout cas répondre sur le fait que est-ce
que on ne peut pas envisager finalement
une une révision des prix
d'une révision de la tarification pour
les médicaments essentiels chaque fois
que le prix le prix de vente est
inférieur au prix de revient industriel
et j'ai bien dit le prix de revient
industriel j'ai pas dit j'ai pas dit le
coût de production j'ai vraiment là j'ai
pris voilà est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
parce que on voit quand même que il y a
une une tendance à un espèce de
je dirais pas de chantage parce que le
mot est fort mais de menaces en tout cas
de ne plus produire des médicaments
matures du fait de la faiblesse des prix
donc est-ce que il n'y a pas cette
possibilité là et alors après on peut
même aller plus loin parce que au départ
la clause de sauvegarde si je ne m'abuse
elle était pas destinée aux produits aux
médicaments matures elle était plutôt
destinée aux médicaments innovants donc
est-ce que c'est c'est parfaitement ça
n'irait pas d'exclure les les
médicaments matures de la clause de
sauvegarde quand je dis ça n'irait pas
c'est à dire est-ce que est-ce que c'est
aberrant est-ce que c'est envisageable
d'envoyer plusieurs gradations dans mes
questions c'est à dire exclure c'est
carrément radical ou sinon envisager une
révision de la tarification pour
permettre
effectivement à ce qui est passé c'est
ces problèmes concernant les
voilà donc c'est plus précis ça dépasse
peut-être un peu votre enfin vous êtes
un expert en matière alors comme je vous
l'ai indiqué effectivement ce n'est pas
les sujets la clause de sauvegarde ce
n'est pas les sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes directement à l'initiative et à
la manœuvre première remarque deuxième
remarque dans les questions que vous
posez en fait on arrive très vite à deux
sujets qui sont le sujet de la
régulation globale et le sujet de la
clause de sauvegarde
la régulation globale c'est la
régulation par baisse de prix et
éventuellement la clause de sauvegarde à
l'origine et la logique du système c'est
que la régulation qui est nécessaire
pour revenir sur la trajectoire qui a
été souhaitée par le gouvernement et le
Parlement la régulation se fait par des
baisses de prix bon et la clause de
sauvegarde n'intervient que si pour une
raison ou pour une autre les baisses de
prix n'ont pas été suffisantes pour
revenir sur la trajectoire
donc normalement le
l'application de la régulation elle se
fait par baisse de prix et les baisses
de prix c'est nous qui en sont en charge
pour le coup nous commettait économique
des produits de santé et c'est une
démarche que nous faisons au cas par cas
et donc nous sommes en situation de
faire des choix sur les baisses de prix
que nous demandons aux entreprises
la difficulté
des dernières années c'est le fait que
la clause de sauvegarde qui normalement
ne se déclenche que
dans l'hypothèse ou les baisses de prix
n'ont pas été suffisantes cette clause
de sauvegarde s'est déclenchée
et se déclenche d'une manière qui dans
des proportions de plus en plus
importantes en conservant le caractère
imprévisible qui était le sien à
l'origine puisque en moyenne ça ne
devait ne pas se déclencher donc ça
pouvait se déclencher une année ne pas
se déclencher l'année suivante etc bon
il reste une dimension imprévisible
parce que les facteurs de déclenchement
les données qui sont nécessaires pour en
décider le déclenchement ne sont décidés
que tardivement et c'est un problème
pour les entreprises tout le monde de
tout le monde le reconnaît mais du coup
lorsque vous parlez de sélectivité de
traitement différenciés de quels sont
les entreprises qui vont être concernées
moi je dirais par la régulation il faut
distinguer ces deux leviers qui sont
aujourd'hui en œuvre ce que nous faisons
à travers les baisses de prix
et je l'ai dit c'est du c'est du cas par
cas et ce qui peut se passer avec la
clause de sauvegarde qui est
l'application de règle et la règle de
base c'est il y a un montant que l'on
doit trouver à travers cette clause de
sauvegarde pour revenir sur la
trajectoire et ce montant de
contribution on va le répartir en
entreprise ou prorata de leur chiffre
d'affaires mais voyez bien qu'on a
plusieurs logiques pour ce qui nous
concerne
et vous demandez madame qu'elle était
notre intervention dans les arbitrages
du PLFSS
premièrement nous ne sommes pas en
charge du calcul de ce qu'est le temps
dans le ciel ce qu'on appelle le temps
dans le ciel la dépense spontanée bon
nous ne sommes pas non plus
impliqués dans la discussion de ce
qu'est la trajectoire cible ça c'est un
débat de société c'est un débat au
Parlement c'est un débat politique donc
la régulation c'est la différence entre
les deux
passé était assez explicitement orienté
sur les produits anciens que l'on
pouvait financer l'arrivée de produits
nouveau
donc dès le mois de juillet en réalité
nous commençons à l'exercice plutôt nous
essayons d'identifier des classes
thérapeutiques qui peuvent être
concernées par un plan de baisse qui
peuvent être ce que ça veut dire qu'ils
peuvent être qui peuvent être parce que
elles correspondent à des critères
légaux qui nous sont donnés sur les
baisses de prix et parmi ces critères il
y en particulier l'ancienneté
l'ancienneté d'un produit bon on regarde
aussi très naturellement
on regarde on regarde très naturellement
si telle classe a déjà fait l'objet de
d'une baisse dans le cadre du plan de
baisse de l'année précédente pour éviter
de revenir deux années de suite sur les
mêmes produits on regarde évidemment
quelle est l'évolution de la dépense
dans tel ou tel secteur donc nous
essayons d'identifier certaines classes
nous en discutons au sein du comité et
dès le mois de juillet nous communiquons
les classes la liste des classes que
nous envisageons de cibler aux
entreprises pour leur donner de la
visibilité donc là c'est ce qui se
passera en principe cette année en
juillet prochain on donnera auxlem et
aux entreprises une information sur les
classes qui seront visées par les
baisses de prix en 2024 et dès le mois
d'août
nous commençons à avoir des échanges
avec les entreprises en leur disant
voilà vous avez tel et tel produit qui
sont concernés par les classes
thérapeutiques ciblées et
on pense vous demander x% de baisse nous
vous écoutons et on écoute ce que les
entreprises ont à nous dire sur leur
capacité à supporter ces messes de prix
ou pas et
simultanément il y a des débats
interministériels précédant les
arbitrages et en général on nous demande
un avis en nous disant voilà les calculs
de régulation disent que on aurait sans
doute besoin de tel ordre de grandeur de
baisse mettons un milliard pour avoir un
chiffre rond
qu'est-ce qui vous paraît faisable
au regard de l'exercice je dirais
botomup que vous êtes en train de
constituer ce que nous dans ce cas là on
regarde classe par classe produit par
produit et on additionne et on se dit
bah on pense que on peut arriver à telle
ou tel montant la difficulté que nous
avons en ce moment et depuis un an ou
deux c'est que dire
on peut arriver enfin un montant de 800
millions comme c'est le cas cette année
nous paraît réalisable par la voie
conventionnelle ce n'est pas du tout la
même chose suivant que c'est 800
millions
qui doivent constituer l'ensemble de la
régulation globale ou que derrière il va
y avoir une clause de sauvegarde qui va
s'appliquer pour des montants dont les
ordres de grandeur commencent à
approcher c'est
ces chiffres là quand on va voir une
entreprise en lui demandant une baisse
si elle pense que derrière elle va de
toute façon être redevable d'une remise
pour un montant équivalent sur
l'incitation négocier avec nous et plus
faible voilà mais nous notre rôle encore
une fois c'est de partir d'une
appréciation qui soit classe par classe
entreprise par entreprise pour essayer
de dire voilà ce que l'on pense pouvoir
faire par la voie conventionnelle en
trouvant un accord et avec une signature
à la fin
et le montant de la régulation ce n'est
ce n'est pas nous qui en sont
responsable alors ensuite votre question
était plus précisément mais je tenais à
vous dire quels sont les leviers nous de
notre côté dans cet exercice de baisse
de prix suivant les instructions que
nous avons suivant les orientations
politiques on va pouvoir décider
d'épargner éventuellement telle ou telle
classe de produits
ça c'est quelque chose qui est possible
on regarde d'orientation enfin de
priorité de priorité politique
ensuite il y a la question de la clause
de sauvegarde donc la clause de
sauvegarde le
moi parce que vous avez donné comme
critères l'an
cienne
pour nous en fait ce qui nous ce que
nous trompons pertinents pardon c'est le
service médical rendu quel que soit
l'ancienneté du médicament vous voyez
c'est pas un médicament peut être ancien
et être extrêmement
efficace et très important pour les
patients et et pourquoi est-ce qu'il va
subir une baisse de prix justement par
rapport à l'ancienneté donc c'est le
service médical rendu et donc ma
question c'est est-ce qu'il y a aucun
moment par exemple la DGS intervient
avec vous auprès de vous à vos côtés
pour vous signifier justement c'est
important que c'est un problème de santé
publique alors sur tous les sujets que
nous sommes amenés à traiter la DGS est
au sein du comité pour pouvoir exprimer
ses priorités de santé publique ça c'est
clair et en général nous nous l'écoutons
mais sur les critères que vous avez sur
les critères que de mise en oeuvre si
vous regardez le l 162 16-4 du code de
la sécurité sociale qui est dans notre
Bible ça définit les critères légaux ça
définit les critères légaux de fixation
du prix et ensuite les critères légaux
selon lesquels un prix peut être baissé
bon et il y a 7 critères le premier
c'est la loi donc on l'applique le
premier c'est l'ancienneté de
l'inscription de la spécialité concernée
ou des médicaments à même visé
thérapeutique
parce qu'en fait c'est ce que vous
expliquez que vous que vous répétez
à loisir c'est qu'en fait ce
raisonnement c'est de dire on suppose
que l'ancienneté va permettre de faire
des économies d'échelle et des économies
parce que le produit est amorti etc
c'est ça qui repose dans la légitimité
de ce critère c'est donc on part
finalement on prend comme point de
départ un modèle économique qui est
peut-être problématique aujourd'hui quoi
parce qu'on ne prend pas en compte
Corinne tu avais une question là-dessus
très précise
merci madame le Président mais je veux
pas je vais pas vous interrompre si vous
aviez non non mais je partage ce que
vous dites juste je reviens une toute
petite remarque mais de précisions vous
avez évoqué monsieur le l'émission de
prix au cas par cas on est d'accord
classe thérapeutique par classe
thérapeutique
quand on construit le plan de baisse on
commence par identifier des classes
thérapeutiques on est d'accord et une
année donnée on dit telle classe
thérapeutique et visée par le tel groupe
de produits du coup est visé par le par
la baisse de prix et ensuite on discute
entreprise par entreprise et vous avez
des produits qui n'ont pas la même asmr
par exemple ou qui n'ont pas et qui
n'ont pas tous les mêmes indications
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est obligé de
rentrer dans le détail
je vous laisse
c'était par rapport je faisais le
parallèle avec les augmentations que
vous étudiez parfois au cas par cas
parfois par classe thérapeutique vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et là c'était
les diminutions de Pré au cas par cas
c'était de préciser dans une vous
choisissez comme une classe
thérapeutique comme vous l'avez dit
ensuite et après c'est au cas par cas en
fonction des médicaments
première question alors je partage les
propos de la présidente parce que vous
avez dit il y aura toujours un plan de
baisse de prix
d'accord mais est-ce que cette
affirmation
et immuable et est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train en train d'entretenir ce phénomène
de Penny tout simplement c'est à dire
que c'est pour ça que c'était la
question du modèle économique c'est pour
ça que je vous posais aussi la question
de votre
des échanges que vous aviez avec le
ministère et et la CNAM vous voyez
se dire un moment si vous l'expert en
termes de prix le prix est au cœur du
sujet certes on a un modèle économique
et et que on sait pourquoi on demande
toujours l'effort du médicament parce
qu'une simple décision de base de prix
fait que aussitôt c'est de l'argent qui
sort pas des caisses de la Sécurité
sociale donc c'est vous votre expertise
et
remonter au niveau du ministère il faut
peut-être qu'on fasse une pause sinon on
va entretenir le phénomène vous voyez
enfin de mon point de vue mais je peux
me tromper bien évidemment et est-ce que
les dernières questions je n'arrêterai
là est-ce que parce qu'on l'a vu par le
passé on a vu des remboursements au cas
par cas soit décision unilatérale soit
décision de laboratoire on a vu des
dérembissements par classe thérapeutique
ce qui a généré des reports de
prescription sur des médicaments souvent
plus chers c'est quelque chose que
j'observe moins sauf à la demande
d'élaboratoires qu'en est-il de cette
politique de déremboursement aussi de
médicaments
alors je reviens sur vos questions et
puis des questions de principe sur la
place de l'ancienneté d'abord une
précision
bon nous appliquons la loi vous n'en
serez pas surpris mais la loi ne dit pas
que le prix de vente doit être baissé la
loi elle dit que le comité peut procéder
à des baisses de prix dès lors que l'un
des critères ci-dessous et renseignés
c'est pour ça que je vous indiquais que
au moment de concevoir les plans de
baisse
quand nous examinons des classes et
quand nous après nous discutons avec les
entreprises nous pouvons faire preuve de
discernement c'est une phase dans
laquelle on discute avec les entreprises
qui peuvent nous expliquer des problèmes
de non-viabilité qui peuvent aussi nous
expliquer si vous voulez le le Katy pour
lequel on est confronté aussi c'est une
entreprise qui spontanément va être
affectée du fait des classes
thérapeutiques que l'on a choisi une
année donnée elle peut être
affectée sur une part trop importante de
son portefeuille donc dans ce cas là on
va en tenir compte dans des baisses que
l'on va lui demander donc on essaye de
faire cela au cas par cas mais oui le
premier critère qui nous est donné c'est
de regarder l'ancienneté mais
l'ancienneté c'est parce que cela
revient simplement à dire que il y a une
régulation que l'action de l'État en
matière de prix des médicaments ne
consiste pas simplement à fixer un prix
une fois et pour l'éternité on va
pouvoir procéder à des hausses on doit
pouvoir procéder à des baisses
si vous voulez n'importe si on n'était
pas dans un marché administré comme le
médicament vous avez un modèle qui est
sur le marché le jour où des concurrents
arrivent et bien le modèle qui était là
auparavant il va sans doute pour ne pas
perdre trop de parts de marché à baisser
son prix c'est normal ça se passe comme
ça ensuite qu'il y ait parce que votre
votre sujet bien entendu n'est pas n'est
pas du tout caricatural c'est que il y a
des produits qui sont des produits
battus anciens sur lesquels au fil du
temps
les marges se sont érodées et à un
moment donné si on demande des baisses
de prix supplémentaires on va ça devient
juste impossible on comprend bien ce
sujet là mais à mon sens ça ne remet pas
encore le principe selon lequel il faut
qu'il y ait une régulation qui tienne
compte aussi de l'ancienneté des de
l'ancienneté des produits
mais
encore une fois vous avez en tête une
priorité qui est une prime priorité qui
est la question de lutter contre les
pénuries ça peut être la question de
soutenir tel ou tel
ou tel produit ou tel ou telle classe au
titre de priorité de santé publique il y
a toute une série de domaines dans
lesquels les choix politiques et les
priorités gouvernementales peuvent
s'exprimer s'il y a des priorités
gouvernementales qui sont qui sont
exprimés nous pouvons en tenir compte
dans la conception de nos plans de
baisse et il n'est pas interdit de d'en
tenir compte dans la clause de
sauvegarde il y a un débat c'est pas un
mystère il y a un débat aujourd'hui vous
y avez été confronté sur est-ce que les
produits génériques doivent être dans la
clause de sauvegarde ou pas
bon voilà il y a d'autres modalités on a
des enfin on peut on peut discuter
là-dessus s'il y a quelque chose à faire
sur les génériques ça peut passer par
les discussions conventionnelles que
nous avons à l'occasion des des comités
de suivi de générique quand ils ont lieu
ça peut passer par le
l'attitude vis-à-vis de la clause de
sauvegarde il y a toute une série de
modalités qui sont sur la table
effectivement vous avez vous avez eu
raison de souligner la difficulté parce
que une un médicament qui qui est ancien
de fait il a il a permis à un certain
nombre d'entreprises de laboratoire etc
d'avoir des marges de importantes et
donc au fil du temps normal dans le
marché tel qu'il est qu'il est fait de
baisser les prix mais là on est quand
même sur des sur des
le médicament n'est pas n'est pas une
marchandise donc en tout cas pour moi
donc et c'est ça la difficulté c'est que
en fait on est quand même sur sur un
marché et on est obligé de tenir
j'allais dire tous les tous les bouts de
la chaîne donc à la fois il faut quand
même prendre en compte parce que c'est
une question de santé publique pour moi
le service médical rendu ça me paraît
extrêmement important vous avez dit que
effectivement vous en teniez enfin il y
avait ces discussions etc et que vous en
teniez compte à tout à tout moment bon
mais c'est un fait mais après dans dans
la réflexion qu'on peut avoir mais sans
déséquilibrer le système parce que
Corinne l'a dit on est quand même pris
un peu dans un étau parce que à la fois
il y a quand même cette ondame avec une
enveloppe fermée
il y a la clause de sauvegarde et c'est
important qu'elle existe de mon point de
vue mais est-ce que il faut pas
l'aménager et est-ce que il faut pas
sortir les médicaments matures de cette
clause de sauvegarde elle a et je le
redis parce que vous avez pas répondu
tout à fait en tout cas j'ai pas entendu
au départ elle est pas conçue pour enfin
me semble-t-il elle est pas conçue pour
les pour les pour les médicaments
matures où je me trompe
je n'ai pas l'historique de la
construction de la clause de sauvegarde
et je n'ai pas non plus la définition de
ce que sont des produits matures c'est
pour ça que j'utilisais le terme de
d'ancienneté c'est dans la vie d'un
médicament il y a il y a différentes
phases les produits matures souvent le
débat porte sur une catégorie qui elle
est bien définie qui sont les produits
génériques et les produits matures ça
relève d'une problématique un peu
générale mais qui n'est pas codifiée ou
avec un périmètre qui soit bien bien
connu mais on va dire générique
si on dit les génériques alors les
génériques je vais faire une une petite
parenthèse ce que nous faisons sur les
produits génériques les baisses que nous
sommes nous amenés à prononcer en effet
dans un cadre conventionnel
d'une part parce que on a des règles qui
sont dans la corcadre et qui indiquent à
quel moment on peut quels sont les
points de rendez-vous au bout de combien
de mois après l'introduction de produits
génériques on prend une photographie et
on regarde quel est le degré de
substitution du générique au princeps et
à ce moment-là on voit qu'est-ce qu'il
faut qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour que
le développement
des génériques se poursuivent et puis on
peut prononcer des des baisses on le
fait dans un cadre conventionnel vous
avez fait référence je crois madame la
rapporteur au fait que il y avait eu un
moratoire je crois que vous en avez
parlé non c'est moi qui l'ai c'est moi
qui l'ai imaginé vous avez sans doute
pensé moratoire qui avait été décidé et
puis grosse cibler qui avait été qui
avait été annoncé
en principe on le fait dans un cadre
conventionnel on n'a pas pu le faire
dans un cadre conventionnel parce que
les représentants des entreprises ont
préféré boycotter et ils l'ont ils l'ont
revendiqué ou effort je pense devant
votre commission je voulais simplement
dire que je le regrette
nous avons un cadre conventionnel qui
fonctionne et je souhaite que l'avenir
il puisse reprendre ses travaux donc je
profite de l'occasion pour dire que je
souhaite que à l'avenir les
représentants des entreprises
reviennent et
j'avais été un peu frappé par des propos
que j'avais trouvé excessif enfin tel
qu'ils ont été rapportés par une agence
de presse donc je ne sais pas si c'est
si le prononcé fait foi mais
nous sommes dans une logique où nous
mettons sur la table
les
les produits les groupes du répertoire
des génériques sur lesquels nous pouvons
envisager une baisse et après nous
écoutons des entreprises
et nous nous retirons de la liste un
certain nombre de produits parce que les
entreprises nous expliquent que là pour
telle ou telle raison ce n'est pas
possible c'est vraiment ce que nous
faisons et jusqu'à présent ça toujours
fonctionner ce sont des vrais
négociations en un point d'entrée on a
un point de sortie le point de sortie
est soit différent soit très différent
de ce qui était le point d'entrée parce
que la négociation se déroule
normalement
c'est pour ça que j'ai été un peu étonné
de ce que j'ai lu d'une audition que
vous avez conduites dans laquelle un
représentant du du j'aime à utiliser des
mots très dures ou très critiques notre
égard et en faisant mine de considérer
que ce que nous avions mis sur la table
en point d'entrée était un point de
sortie que nous cherchions à imposer
si le gemme a des inquiétudes parlons-en
mais ce n'est pas comme ça que cela
marche et en février nous avions pour
une organisation représentative je crois
que le terme est clair il y avait du
grain à moudre il y a beaucoup de grains
moudre dans une négociation notre
souhait et que les négociations se
déroulent normalement
je ne vais pas souhaiter qu'on arrive à
la table et négociations en mettant sur
la table un point d'entrée qui est aussi
un point de sortie ça serait la négation
donc ce n'est pas correct de de faire
comme si ce que nous avions mis sur la
table était un point de sortie c'est
facile après de son scandaliser et de
dire c'est inadmissible oui mais ce
n'est pas la réalité la réalité c'est
que nous cherchons année haussier de
même que lorsque nous mettons en place
les plans de baisse car nous allons voir
les entreprises de manière générale
ingénérique ou autre à partir de du mois
d'août on a un point d'entrée en
négociation et évolue ensuite voilà
c'était une c'était une parenthèse sur
les génériques la question que vous
posiez sur faut-il
quel traitement pour les génériques
faut-il les retirer de la clause de
sauvegarde c'est un voilà c'est un choix
politique ils n'ont pas toujours été
dans la clause de sauvegarde c'est vrai
ils sont maintenant si on souhaite enfin
voilà c'est un débat c'est un débat
politique nous
nous que ce soit en matière de
régulation par baisse de prix ou de
régulation par la clause de sauvegarde
simplement nous constatons qu'il y a des
objectifs et que on les applique sur un
certain nombre de produits si l'assiette
se réduit l'exercice devient de plus en
plus difficile parce que les les
produits que l'on va aller chercher
entre guillemets on va devoir les
solliciter d'une manière
très forte
je crois que Corinne merveille encore
poser une question
que je vais être obligé de vous quitter
je vous prenne mon excuser c'était sur
l'article 65 de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale
et a priori
donc les règles j'allais dire ont été
fixées avec une majoration du prix pour
les les médicaments qui seraient
produits sur le territoire national ou
en Europe si je ne m'abuse mais
uniquement pour les nouveaux médicaments
est-ce que vous envisagez cette même
application pour des médicaments anciens
et dans quel délai
alors effectivement
la loi la loi ne fait pas la distinction
et là où il y a une distinction c'est
dans le mode opératoire que nous avons
retenu
après de longues discussions internes au
comité donc nous avons aujourd'hui un
mode opératoire pour pouvoir appliquer
l'article 65 à des produits ou des
indications qui arrivent enfin des
produits sur des indications qui
arrivent en primant inscription et nous
n'avons pas
l'équivalent pour ce qui est des
produits qui sont déjà existants
que ce soit pour prononcer des des
hausses éventuelles ou que ce soit pour
ne pas prononcer des baisses dans le
cadre d'un plan baisse donc voilà les
questions qui sont sur la table
aujourd'hui c'est l'article 65 est-ce
que vous l'utilisez dans le cadre de des
programmes de des plantes de baisse pour
épargner certains produits ou est-ce que
pour des produits existants vous pouvez
prononcer des
aujourd'hui du coup comment procédons
comment procédons-nous aujourd'hui il y
a plusieurs il y a plusieurs sujets sur
des produits existants qui demanderaient
une hausse
dès lors que ils existent et qu'ils
demandent une hausse nous avons un
vecteur qui est opérationnel qui est
justement l'article 28 donc
un produit existant qui est confronté à
une difficulté et qui porte un risque
sur la sécurité d'approvisionnement il
sait que de toute façon il y a déjà
quelque chose qui est opérationnel qui
est l'article 28 donc il peut le
mobiliser
je précise que dans l'article 28 le mot
capacité d'approvisionnement figure déjà
terme qui est repris dans l'article 65
donc il est tout à fait possible de
venir nous voir au titre de l'article 28
ce qui est ce qui est différent c'est
que la première question que nous allons
poser on en a parlé à propos de
l'article 28 ça va être quelle est la
hausse de coût
à laquelle vous êtes confronté
et ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que si le
produit est éligible au titre de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement etc la
hausse de prix à laquelle nous allons
pouvoir procéder via l'article 28 ce
n'est pas forcément les 15% que l'on a
retenu comme mode opératoire pour
l'article 65 voilà
mais je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui pour
l'entreprise est le plus ou moins
avantageux et en particulier l'article
65 qui permet de relever de 15%, c'est
jusqu'à 15% parce que quand on instruit
l'article 65 on regarde comme vous le
savez la sécurité d'approvisionnement
que que permet la localisation des sites
ce qui veut dire que on regarde d'abord
s'il y a un enjeu de sécurité
d'approvisionnement est-ce que le
médicament est essentiel ou pas
et après on a une analyse qui est
largement conduite par la Direction
générale des entreprises sur l'analyse
de la chaîne de valeur où ça se passe ou
est fabriqué le le principe actif ou est
fabriqué le produit le médicament
lui-même ou est-ce qu'il est conditionné
et à partir de là on va pouvoir au titre
de l'article 65 prononcé des Hans qui
seront jusqu'à 15%. mais si vous avez un
produit pour lesquels le principe actif
étant Chine le produit fini
est au Maroc et le conditionnement est
en France la hausse de prix ne sera pas
de 15%. nous avons une grille ça ne sera
pas de 15%. donc suivant les suivants
les cas
un article enfin le mode de calcul de
l'article 28 ou le mode de calcul de
l'article 65 peuvent se révéler plus ou
moins avantageux pour l'entreprise
sachez simplement que
il n'y a pas un article qui soit a
priori systématiquement plus favorable
du point de vue de d'une point de vue
des entreprises ce qui est vrai c'est
que en disant aux entreprises existantes
si vous voulez une hausse passée par
l'article 28 ça veut dire que on leur
demande de documenter une hausse de
coûts donc s'il n'y a pas de hausse de
coût
l'article 28 ne va pas produire de de
hausse donc c'est c'est là qu'il y a
peut-être un sujet mais en même temps
s'il n'y a pas de hausse de coût on peut
penser que il y a pas forcément la même
urgence que pour un produit qui est
directement confronté à un choc de coût
mais je peux prendre la parole oui
c'était pas l'esprit d'article 65 de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale l'idée c'était éviter les
ruptures d'approvisionnement relocaliser
la production j'entends bien que le
principe actif et donc du coup
on regarde aussi énorme pour y installer
une industrie chimique dans notre pays
reconnaître ça et derrière effectivement
c'est sécuriser l'approvisionnement là
vous l'avez dit la loi ne fait pas de
distinction entre les médicaments
nouveaux et les médicaments anciens pour
l'instant vous sauf erreur de ma part
vous avez écrit ou en tout cas les
modalités d'application de la loi que
pour les médicaments nouveaux ça veut
dire que pour les médicaments anciens il
ne reste que l'article 28 de la loi
cadre donc il y a une inégalité quelque
part de traitement entre d'un côté les
médicaments anciens dans la production
pour être relocalisé dans notre pays et
les médicaments nouveaux pour lequel
voilà c'est j'ai pas de question je
c'est juste une remarque de ma part
mais je vous laisse répondre à la
rapporteur et à la présidente non non
mais pas pour aller dans le même sens
que que Corinne en fait le problème
c'est que l'article 28 ne fait pas de de
distinction avec des entreprises sur le
sol français européen
ça c'est quelque chose de positif vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est à dire
que on est en train il y a quelque chose
quand même de contradictoire on est en
train tout est tous de militer en faveur
de la relocalisation et il y a pas une
une prise en compte de ces entreprises
qui font l'effort ou qui je sais pas
comment l'exprimer mais oui qui en tout
cas sont sur le territoire français vous
n'allez pas particulièrement
être plus
favorable avec une entreprise qui va
relocaliser sa production du début à la
fin
l'article 28 encore une fois c'est le la
logique de l'article 28 c'est y a-t-il y
a-t-il un risque et y a-t-il un enjeu de
sécurité d'approvisionnement c'est la
première chose que nous regardons et il
se trouve que l'article 65 donc qui lui
a force de loi au sens strict
mais en avant la sécurité
d'approvisionnement que garantit donc ça
que on est ou pas un mode opératoire
spécifique pour les produits anciens un
produit qui vient nous voir au titre de
l'article 28 de la corde s'il met en jeu
la sécurité des silmé en avant la
sécurité d'approvisionnement en mettant
en avant sa chaîne de valeur et une
production ou une relocalisation en
France oui bien sûr nous le prenons en
compte
ça c'est très clair et je vous ai dit
que même dès le début dès le début de
l'article 28 avant qu'il n'y ait
l'article 65 et alors que ce n'était pas
inscrit explicitement dans l'article 28
nous avons communiqué sur le fait que
des coups de relocalisation par exemple
pouvaient être pris en compte parce que
dès 2021 la lettre d'orientation qui
nous a été adressée nous ceps par le
gouvernement mentionné cet enjeu de
sécurité d'approvisionnement en me
disant de l'avoir à l'esprit dans
chacune de nos actions donc dans
l'article 28 nous posons ces questions
là bon maintenant il y a sans doute un
besoin de clarification sur la façon
dont nous pouvons mobiliser l'article 65
pour des produits existants que ce soit
pour des demandes de hausse ou que ce
soit dans le cadre de de plan de baisse
et ça c'est quelque chose à quoi nous
devons travailler je pense que les
membres du comité notamment à la
direction générale des entreprises qui
travaillent sur tout ce qui est
politique de relocalisation en ce sujet
en tête et ont en tête le sujet de la
façon de l'écrire dans le dans la
doctrine si vous voulez du CEPS
mais je vous en prie
moi j'ai une toute dernière question
c'est en fait concernant le pilotage du
système d'une manière générale alors là
ça dépasse le simple rang du CEPS mais
on a eu le sentiment lors de nos
auditions que c'était quand même un
petit peu confus et est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il serait important
utile nécessaire qu'il y ait un
secrétariat général par exemple qui soit
vraiment dédié aux médicaments et qui
puissent à un moment donné être celui
unique du donneur d'ordre pour pour
pouvoir animer cette politique du
médicament
en lien avec le Premier ministre où en
lien avec le ministre de la santé mais
voilà qui est quelque chose parce que il
y a beaucoup de d'acteurs et d'actrices
dans le monde du médicament et on a
quand même le sentiment que parfois du
coup les décisions sont un petit peu
longue à venir ou en tout cas ne sont
pas clairement exprimés
vous me demandez de m'élever au dessus
de ma condition ce que je ne peux pas
faire
je n'aurais pas de la légitimité pour
cela mais vous avez dit il y a beaucoup
d'acteurs mais nous avons beaucoup de
registres que dont il faut tenir compte
dans définissant la politique on a
souvent parlé à propos du CEPS
d'injonction contradictoires parce que
nous avons un instrument et voilà et on
attend en matière de politique du
médicament de favoriser à la fois
bien entendu l'accès des patients en
soins dans les meilleures conditions de
s'assurer de la pérennité des produits
matures de s'assurer de la juste
reconnaissance de l'innovation de
veiller à la dimension
industrielle et naturellement de
respecter le cadre budgétaire qui est
défini par l'ONDAM et voyez que il y a
plusieurs objectifs il y a plusieurs
registres il y a plusieurs
d'expertise qui sont qui sont demandées
on a
nous par exemple au CEPS nous prenons
comme des données tout ce qui relèvent
du registre scientifique ce qui est le
champ de de la Haute Autorité de santé
on a donc on n'a pas cette expertise là
on n'a pas l'expertise scientifique en
revanche au sein du comité on est
capable de s'exprimer sur différents
registres puisque on a la Direction
générale de la santé puisque on a la
dimension industrielle analyse de la
chaîne de valeur etc qui peut être prise
en charge par la DGE nous avons aussi la
DGCCRF pour éviter les sujets de
distorsion de de concurrence qui
pourrait intervenir on en a pas on en a
pas parlé nous avons la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale pour les pour ses
compétences budgétaires voilà on est
dans un système qui est complexe
alors je ne sais pas si il est confus je
n'ai pas de doute qu'il y ait des
progrès qui soit possible en matière de
de plus grande transparence mais nous
sommes de toute façon dans un système
qui est complexe parce qu'il y a des
enjeux qui sont à la fois importants et
qui portent sur des registres très
différents donc la capacité à être un
acteur qui qui rassemble toutes ces
dimensions c'est voilà c'est délicat
déjà au sein du CEPS même en laissant de
côté l'aspect scientifique dont j'ai dit
qu'il ne nous concernait pas tout le
reste c'est déjà un champ de domaine de
d'intervention qui est
qui est très large mais une
recommandation sur la gouvernance je ne
peux pas la faire
je crois que Madame la rapporteur n'a
plus de questions à vous poser il me
reste à vous remercier de vous être
soumis à cette deuxième audition je
crois qu'un questionnaire vous a été
envoyé vous avez répondu partiellement
donc on attend la suite et on se
permettra de vous renvoyer quelques
questions si en cours de réflexion on a
de nouveau des interrogations en tout
cas merci et je vous souhaite une bonne
fin de journée merci à vous et bien
entendu nous répondrons au mieux nos
capacités aux nombreuses questions que
vous nous avez ou que vous allez nous
poser merci